Українці полюбляють дизельні автівки.
Ось цей Вольксваген Пассат з еко-стандартом Євро 5 щойно прибув із Німеччини.
Автомеханіки ретельно перевіряють автівку.
Найпізніше за місяць легковик має бути пристосований до українських доріг та умов.
Приміром, прибирають каталізатор.
- Проблема каталізаторів сажових фільтрів цих нових моделей у тому,
що вони виходять із ладу, забиваються
в саму першу чергу із-за неякісного пального.
Без системи очистки вихлопних газів
дизельні автівки забруднюють повітря отруйними вихлопами.
Але оскільки в Україні ніхто не контролює
технічний стан легковиків, проблема вирішується просто.
Автомеханіки прибирають систему очистки вихлопних газів
і заміняють її звичайними трубами.
Ось ця, приміром, від Рено Дизель.
Бо якщо каталізатор забитий, авто не заведеться.
- Ми приїжджаємо, дивимося комп’ютером,
дивимося, в чому проблема.
А проблеми бувають, що забитий каталізатор.
Бувають моменти, що вирізаєм, а буває,
що можна і зремонтувати його.
Луцьк. Це місто - в топ-десятці в Україні
за забрудненістю повітря.
82% речовин, що забруднюють довкілля,
спричиняють саме автомобілі.
Двічі на тиждень у місті працює авторинок,
де найбільший попит нині - на дизельні авто.
Переважну більшість цих машин завозять із Німеччини.
Дизелі з застарілими еко-стандартами
зареєстровані у Польщі або Литві, однак в Україні
на них можна їздити протягом року.
Імпортувати дозволено лише автомобілі зі стандартом Євро 5.
- Як Німеччина переживає за екологію,
дизельні машини зразу же падають в ціні, тому що
держава іде їм назустріч,
компенсує і кредитами,
компенсує, щоб екологію зберегти.
Якість повітря в Луцьку перевіряють щодня
на кількох вимірювальних станціях.
Ще гірші показники - лише у двох інших українських міст.
А тепер до Луцька ще й масово завозять потримані дизельні автівки з Німеччини.
- Звичайно, буде забруднене більше,
тому що дизельне пальне є якраз той
приклад пального, який є досить шкідливий для екології.
Україна - не єдина країна у Східній Європі, де
залюбки купують дизельні автівки з ФРН.
Схоже, Німеччина просто експортує свою дизельну проблему.